you don't need to be a genius to figure
out that the claims made by outgoing
White House dr. Ronnie Jackson about
Donald Trump's health just weren't true
a little while ago Ronnie Jackson said
that Trump was six feet three inches
tall that he weighed 239 and that he
could potentially live to 200 years of
age if he just ate a little bit better
and exercised more right so you did not
need too much thought to realize that's
not true you also don't have to be a
genius to figure out that back during
the campaign when dr. Harold Bornstein
wrote a letter saying Trump is just so
healthy that he would be the healthiest
person ever to be President that wasn't
exactly the type of statement that
doctors would ever make unless there
were very very strange situations that
forced or pushed them into making such a
claim and we've now learned that as part
of the effort to suppress the truth
about Donald Trump's health his doctor's
office was raided by Donald Trump's
bodyguard and lawyer in February of 2017
and all of Donald Trump's medical
records were taken and the raid happened
a couple days after Harold Bornstein
publicly said that he had once
prescribed Donald Trump the hair growth
medication propecia and Bornstein is now
saying that he felt raped frightened and
sad when this happened the Trump
bodyguard in question is of course of
course Keith Schiller who we've
discussed before Bornstein said they
literally took the documents they had no
form that had been signed by Trump
allowing the release of the documents to
either of the people that were there
Sarah Huckabee Sanders was asked about
this yesterday and said it's all
perfectly fine and normal here is
Sarah's explanation as a standard
operating procedure for a new president
the White House medical unit took
possession of the president's article
records it was characterized as a rate
is that your understanding of what
happened the doctors move
about it I know that is not so this
story is not actually about Trump's
health per se this is about the bullying
tactics that are becoming clear in
anything that relates to Trump and it's
also the way that Trump will turn on
people instantly Harold Bernstein is
about 70 years old he had been Trump's
doctor for 35 years
he said he prescribed propecia for hair
loss to Trump and within two days his
office is rated Trump's files are taken
and Bornstein reportedly received a call
basically saying if you were hoping to
be made White House doctor that's not
going to be happening anymore and it's
not just sort of like the insult that is
how Donald Trump behaves there are
possible legal implications here once
your president medical records if seized
and destroyed can be considered
destruction of presidential records also
without authorization taking those
documents without authorization by Trump
this is arguably theft or burglary right
this document certainly didn't belong to
Keith Schiller Trump's bodyguard and
unless Trump's attorney came in with
something signed okay okaying his lawyer
to take those documents or generally
giving his lawyer purview over anything
medically related that's also not
someone that can just come in and grab
documents and of course the White House
is denying that this is what happened
everybody's just denying that this is
what what happened here but there's no
doubt that there is something very odd
taking place here yeah this is Trump
acting as if he's a mob boss and I've
seen it before remember when uh Michael
Cohen sent one of his cronies to
intimidate stormy day allegedly
daughter's day care allegedly of course
but I don't know this is usually how the
president acts right the trend is most
president don't do this type of bullying
and there's countless stories of Trump
and his associates doing the exact same
type of bullying and by the way wrapped
up in this story this is in itself a
scandal but it's only like the tenth
biggest scandal over the last 24 hours
remember when we read that note from dr.
Harold Bornstein and we thought the
language about how Trump would be like
the healthiest president ever the
language wasn't very much reminiscent of
how doctors talk but it was very
reminiscent of how Donald Trump
dr. Harold Bornstein is now claiming
that Trump dictated the letter to him
and that Bornstein merely took it down
and signed it for Trump in five minutes
and gave it to a Trump that was waiting
in a limo a Bornstein told CNN yesterday
quote he meaning Trump dictated the
whole letter I didn't write that letter
I just made it up as I went along and
again people are attacking Bornstein as
a disgruntled former doctor who's just
making up anything he can to hurt Trump
now that Trump's lawyer and bodyguard
raided his office that Trump dictated
the note but from day one we literally
said it sounds like a note written by or
dictated by Donald Trump the propecia
stuff definitely triggered trouble yeah
I mean it's but it was a pretty
hilarious statement to make to because
it's not like Bornstein could have
assessed James Madison's health and
compare the two right so here's how the
right is defending that because
obviously when you say how could a
doctor who hasn't examined every
president in history say that Trump
would be the healthiest president in
history there's a defense that Bornstein
meant of all the recent presidents in
the era of media where you can sort of
like tell how healthy they are on what
basis would a one pound short of obese
seventy year old be healthier than
Barack Obama at a time that Barack Obama
like it's not even believable among the
last two presidents right it was
laughable to begin with and this
actually is a really good opportunity to
refocus our attention on the White House
press secretary the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership